let's just bring you some breaking news  now the government has issued a further  five so-called serious shortage  protocols for the supply of penicillin  and this follows a sharply increased  demand for the antibiotic after an  increase in strep a and scarlet fever  cases across the country now some  pharmacies are experiencing temporary  and localized supply issues and may not  have the specific formulation listed on  the prescription and this allows  pharmacies to give out other forms of  the drug the government has said that  there is no Nationwide shortage but  anecdotal evidence from local pharmacies  have pointed to supply issues so the  latest coming in the government has  issued a further five so-called serious  shortage protocol for the supply of  penicillin